i claude blanchemaison nous vous
retrouverons avec le sont cette fois-ci
nous disions que c'était vraiment révélé
un ursula von der leyen avec la
présentation de ce plan de relance
aujourd'hui oui alors je crois qu'elle a
imposé ce plan aux commissaires qui
constitue le collège de convaincre six
autres commissaires que l a présenté
aujourd'hui au parlement européen et que
l'accueil a été dans l'ensemble très bon
sauf peut-être à l'extrême droite
maintenant évidemment les choses
sérieuses commencent puisqu'il va
falloir aller vers les états membres et
là je pense que madame von der leyen la
fin de l'année de la hyène joue gros jeu
parce que ou bien ça passe
et à ce moment là elle aura on le
reconnaîtra comme une véritable femme
d'état puisque c'est d'expression qu'il
faut utiliser ou bien les états membres
n'arrivent pas à se mettre d'accord et à
ce moment là on l'accusera d'avoir vu
trop grand et de ne pas avoir tenu assez
suffisamment compte de l'opinion des
états du nord donc je pense que l a eu
ce courage de faire cette proposition
aujourd'hui jacques delors l'avait un
peu mise au pied du mur en disant il ya
quelques semaines
s'il n'y a pas une action de solidarité
et bien c'en est fini de l'union
européenne rien que cela est en effet le
marché unique comme le l'euro pourrait
être menacé le creloc blanchemaison en
place un plan écrit lé inédit il est
inédit parce que pour la première fois
on utilise le crédit financier delà de
la commission européenne pour
l'autoriser à faire un gigantesque
emprunt sur les marchés financiers 750
milliards d'euros c'est évidemment
énorme et jusqu'à présent les états
membres ne souhaitait pas que la
commission européenne se lance dans ce
genre d'exercice il y avait un budget
qui était voté en équilibre et qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas avoir des déséquilibres
qui par conséquent ne pouvait pas donner
lieu à des emprunts deuxièmement le
l'élément nouveau c'est effectivement
que avec une partie de cet emprunt la
plus grosse partie 500 milliards et bien
la commission va le faire des
subventions à des programmes présentés
par les états membres pour aider les des
secteurs où les régions les plus
affectées par la crise et puis qu'avec
les 250 millions restants eh bien elle
va faire des prêts également aux états
membres ou dans tout cas certains états
membres pour qu'ils puissent prêter cet
argent au secteur et aux régions les
plus affectées alors la dernière rangée
originalité c'est que le renforcement de
ce set enfin il va être budgété dans le
budget de l'union européenne et bien
laurent pour ce monde sera fait par les
états mans en fonction de la plaie
traditionnelles de financement des
budgets ce qui veut dire que on ne
changera pas la cuvée et l'allemagne par
exemple des finances le budget à environ
26% et bien devoir rembourser 26 % la
france 17%
quelles que soient les sommes reçues
dans le cadre des dons ou des prêts
qu'elles seront les contreparties alors
les contreparties y en a plusieurs
d'abord le fait que naturellement les
états dits frugaux les d'état rigoriste
vont évidemment exigé que ceux qui
bénéficient de dons ou de prêts s'engage
à faire des réformes structurelles
puisque leur thèse c'est que si ces
états sont en mauvaise situation
économique
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas fait
suffisamment de réformes structurelles
dans le passé et il faut donc les frères
auraient évidemment l'italie et
l'espagne considère qu'il s'agit des
traitements une situation d'urgence et
que elles ne veulent pas se mettre sous
une tutelle quelconque justin de
bruxelles
donc c'est une première difficulté la
deuxième difficulté c'est que évidemment
c'est cet emprunt va être budgété il va
donc falloir remonter au moins
temporairement la limite qui est
actuellement assignée au coach de
l'union européenne 1,2 pour cent du pib
et la commission va proposer de le
remonter à 2 % certains états sont
réticents même si c'est pour une période
transitoire
et puis
bourse et cet emprunt et la commission
laissent un peu le sujet ouvert puisque
elle dit de toute façon nous
rembourserons entre 2028 et de 1058 donc
on a le temps de discuter des modalités
avec les états membres et peut-être que
l'on peut disent ils à mettre en place
de nouvelles ressources propres au
budget communautaire
par exemple une taxe carbone par exemple
une taxe sur les grandes entreprises
numériques alors peut-il y avoir encore
dans le faisons à un accord entre les
différents états il faut être très
optimiste pour penser qu'il ya un accord
au conseil européen du 18 et du 19 juin
prochain à bruxelles
ce conseil européen devra être non pas
par vidéoconférence comme le précédent
mais probablement avec la présence
physique parce que ça va être très
difficile
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement et
chacun fera valoir son point de vue
alors c'est d'autant plus compliqué que
parallèlement à ce que nous venons
d'évoquer
il y assure la table la discussion sur
un cadre budgétaire à 7 ans pour l'union
européenne pour lequel la commission
propose que un milliard cent 100
millions d'euros ce qui correspond à peu
près à la projection du budget actuel on
était puis par sept et on obtient à peu
près ceci simplement les états du nord
ou de réduire les fonds consacrés à la
politique agricole commune et voulait
réduire les fonds structurels qui
servent donc pour la petite anecdote
communes essentiellement aux états
méditerranéens au pays de l'est
et puis pour les fonds de cohésion
également beaucoup au pays de l'est
hélas la france naturellement reste
battre pour qu'on ne touche pas à la
politique agricole commune et les pls on
se bat pour qu'on ne touche pas aux
fonds de cohésion
je me demande si d'ailleurs la solution
la plus simple ne serait pas d'essayer
d'avoir un accord sur les grandes lignes
du plan de relance de ce qu'elle était
présente aujourd'hui comme plan de
relance est renvoyé à l'automne
la discussion sur le cadre budgétaire
pluriannuel merci peau de blanche raison
d'avoir été avec nos experts en
relations internationales